[Music]
palestinians in gaza look at yet another
building reduced to rubble
as israel continues its strikes on gaza
from air land
and sea one man describes the moment he
realizes his house was next
i received on my mobile phone a call
from a private number
they said that it was a call from the
israeli intelligence
and they were warning before targeting
our jabbery home
they asked me to clear the area and to
move all the neighbors out
i told him all are out he asked me to
make sure that everyone is out
also he asked me to block the street
israel has one of the most
technologically advanced and well-funded
militaries
in the world while hamas has kept up a
barrage of low-tech rockets
most of them have been destroyed by its
rocket defense system
known as iron dome despite that some
fell on towns near the gaza border
including ashdod on wednesday and some
people were injured
israel's caretaker prime minister
benjamin netanyahu spoke to foreign
diplomats
and was blunt when it came to his stance
on gaza and hamas
there are only two ways that you can
deal with them you can either
conquer them and that's always an open
possibility
or you can deter them and we are engaged
right now in forceful deterrence but i
have to say
we don't rule out anything palestinian
president mahmoud abbas also spoke
hoping for an internationally backed
long-term solution
our work now is focused on stopping the
israeli aggression against our people in
jerusalem west bank and gaza
then entering a serious political
process under clear international
backing
that leads to ending the israeli
occupation of the lands in the state of
palestine
any long-term solution is still a very
long
way off now the united nations can't get
its aid convoy
into the gaza strip israel says there
was a mortar attack at the border
crossing
so therefore they shut it down the
palestinian factions say
that their positions were attacked at
first however
the aid convoy remains exactly where it
is and not
where it's needed the most imran khan al
jazeera
on the southern barrier with gaza